you've been ever summers coming in via
mango curry is my favorite dish which I
have to have to cook and feed people
what I love about the curry is that it's
it's really fresh and vibrant the cool
thing about using the mangos here is
that there's so many different varieties
I've chosen to make a mango caramel
chili dart today
I love mangos and for me mangos is
essentially know the beginning of summer
I lived away from India for a few years
and every season my parents would send
me mangoes and that made me the happiest
girl ever I remember opening my fridge
and just you know getting that whiff of
those fresh a few from Bombay you know
Alphonso mangoes and I decided to use
them today you know my kitchen we had
this big conflict because we all pastry
chefs and everyone loves sweet but there
is us you know certain part of it that
hates sweets true but they love chilies
so and I can't stand spice just by
itself so I decided let me just take
that chili and put in the caramel so we
have a mix of sweet salty and the tart
gives it a nice crunch so we have all
different textures
so here we have mango sticky rice cool
thing about using the mangoes here is
that there's so many different varieties
they all have their special attributes
some are super sweet some are super
floral some are super citrusy some are
super acidic and we just wanted to show
off a couple kinds of mangoes and a
couple of different things that we could
do with them and give a different take
and sweet savory mango dish only has a
lot of desserts you'll see are very
OneNote so all of our desserts we tend
to call them kitchen desserts they're
not your typical pastry chef style
they're always more about balance so
we'll always have a good amount of salt
to our desserts and a lot of different
textures and temperatures and those are
living so they're very different from
your standard desserts
my working thought process for dishes
and stuff it's pretty random a lot of
times I'll wake up by like 3 4 or 5 in
the morning and then I'll just start
writing as soon as I get all these ideas
down I'll come in as soon as early as
possible and I'll actually make the dish
dissect it make it again and it
generally takes depending on the dish
it'll take anywhere from like 20 30 40
tries everything all in the dish
mangu Cory is one of my favorite mango
dishes where mangoes used in a very
unusual form which is to make a curry
it's my grandma's recipe she comes from
Rajasthan and I have given it a chef's
touch by taking the Rajasthani
mango curry of my grandma and giving it
a South Indian touch the first
similarities to this recipe was that at
my grandma's family like her cousin's
place and the beautiful thing about
using mangoes in this season is that
they are nice juicy sweet tangy so first
time I made this curry just without the
pips and I realize okay this is curry
but there is no exciting mouthfeel and
then I added the pips
they became just fantastic because you
can pick them you can bite into them and
you get that wholesome feeling that
you're having a meal
the dish we did today the cheese
liinahamari which is essentially cheese
links which are the small pup snacks we
all grew up eating makes with Carey what
I love about the Carey is that it's
really fresh and vibrant and it's also
versatile you can use it in a whole
bunch of applications but in its best
form it's eaten raw and in this
particular dish it gives a lot of crunch
and Sun is any contrast with the salty
taste of the cheese make an inspiration
for the dish comes from our travels in
across the country and this particular
dish from Kolkata so eating jhaal muri
on the streets of Kolkata but this one
with a slight nostalgic twist
good